do you have windows were clothes that
need modernization keep watching as we
cover how you can use Antos to modernize
and run your Windows applications hi I'm
Priyanka Vergara and welcome to anthers
101 with anthos our goal is to make it
seamless for you to modernize and manage
your workloads in the environments that
you prefer whether it is on from Google
cloud edge or a different cloud with
about 50% of the enterprise workloads
running on Windows servers it's
important to see how Windows workloads
can take advantage of the modernization
benefits that anthos offers up until
recently kubernetes was limited to linux
based applications preventing enterprise
applications running on Windows servers
from taking advantage of the benefits of
agility speed of development and
simplified management last year 2019 the
open-source community brought Windows
service container support in kubernetes
1.1 for building on the OSS
functionality anthos has added several
out-of-the-box security scalability
integration and management capabilities
to features like private cluster support
shielded VMs regional clusters and
industry-first for weight auto scaling
available only in anthos GTA by running
Windows Server apps as containers on
anthos gge you can reduce the licensing
burden and vendor dependencies along
with many of the benefits that linux
applications have enjoyed for years with
the general availability of Windows on
anthos on google cloud you can run your
windows and linux based workloads
side-by-side with the master or control
plane and the node pools attached to it
you can run the s AC semi-annual channel
version or the LTS see the long term
servicing channel version of the Windows
Server in the windows no pools
cubelet and q proxy run natively on the
windows nodes allowing you to run mixed
Windows and Linux container workloads in
the same cluster now whether you're
modernizing an existing Windows app or
creating a new one the first thing that
you need to do is to create a cluster to
deploy your way
those based app to do that in the end
those UI create the cluster provide a
name and add note pool create a node and
select windows semiannual or long-term
service channel as the image and create
once you have the cluster created you
can deploy a new Windows application in
the cluster or migrate an existing
Windows app to migrate an existing
application you could use by great for
anthos v2k for Windows the solution
migrates is web applications asp.net and
Windows Server apps from VMS to Windows
Server 2019 containers on anthos ggae it
automatically extracts application files
and configurations from compute engine
VMs and creates a suggested migration
plan this is an auto-generated plan but
you can customize it if you need it
generates artifacts like a zip file with
application contents and settings and a
docker file with the recipe to build the
deployable image the docker file is then
used to build an image and then validate
the generated image we understand that
modernizing your applications into you
more than just deploying and managing
containers this is why we are working
with several partners to build a strong
ecosystem we're excited to announce that
these partners have already worked to
integrate their solutions with Windows
on anthos Jiki my green fir anthos
provides a fast and simple way to move
existing workloads to modernized
orchestration and application management
without requiring access to source code
rewriting or re-architecting
applications we are committed to helping
you in your modernization journey
regardless of the type of platform or
work loads you use Linux or Windows soon
windows on anthos will be available on
premises and on other clouds to learn
more check out the documentation linked
below and for more anthos content don't
forget to subscribe and follow the
anthos 101 playlist
you
[Music]